كيف شاهدت هذه المباراه شو رسبت داخل هذه
واثقه فيه وثقه في
المدرب اكيد نستحق الفوز اكيد نستحق
والوصل
[تصفيق]
شكرا لك السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم رشا قبل هذه المباراه
كان يعمل ان يصل الى هذه الى المنتخب
المغربي الى
هذا المتكلم عن الفاينال مع النهائي كاس
العالم وان يربح المنتخب المغربي هذه
المباراه وان يكون بطل العالم في كره
القدم لما لا يعني هناك كثير
حتى اللحظه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله المغرب وشكرا قطر
شكرا
[موسيقى]
للوطن العربي شكرا لحكمتها وبراستها قطر
ما قصرت مع احد الكرمه كلها وان شاء الله
بشكل كبير المشهد في الدوحه ايضا الدوحه
نجحت في تنظيم هذا المونديال بشكل جيد
للغايه انعكس في فرحه العرب بهذا التنظيم
وفرحتهم ايضا
بوصول وتاهل المغرب الى المربع الذهبي هذه
الصور الاحتفال الاحتفال هو العنوان
الرئيسي العلم المغربيه تصدر المشهد بشكل
كبير